I'M MR.
THERE'S-GOT-TO-BE-A-BETTER-WAY.
I'VE MADE BILLIONS
FINDING PROBLEMS
AND SELLING SOLUTIONS,
SO I STARTED THIS CHARITY.
NOW I SOLVE
THE WORLD'S PROBLEMS,
THE BIGGER, THE BETTER.
- [clears throat]
UH, MAYBE I COULD HELP TOO.
- YEAH, I DON'T THINK SO.
YOU'RE JUST A JANITOR.
- TRUE, I MAY BE
A LOWLY JANITOR, BUT--
- YOU'RE A TEMP. YOU'RE NOT--
- YEAH, YEAH.
- "TEMP" JANITOR.
THAT'S RIGHT.
BUT KEEP IN MIND,
I HAVE TWO DEGREES:
A MASTER'S
IN COMPLEX MATH PROBLEMS
AND A DOCTORATE IN THE TOUGHEST
CHEMISTRY THERE IS, SO...
- RIGHT, I SEE THAT.
- FRAMED.
GREAT, WELL,
I CAN'T WAIT TO GET STARTED.
SO DOES ANYONE
HAVE A PROBLEM HERE?
- WHEN I WAS FLIPPING THROUGH
MY FAVORITE MAGAZINE
THIS MORNING,
CIGAR CHOMPER...
MMM, THAT'S A YUMMY CIGAR.
YES, THAT'S ME ON THE COVER.
- VERY HANDSOME.
- LOOK INSIDE HERE.
I SAW THIS PHOTO
OF A STARVING CHILD.
- OH.
- LOOK AT THIS KID.
LOOK AT HIM!
- YEAH, I DON'T GET IT.
THERE'S ALL THIS FOOD,
BUT NOT EVERYONE
IS GETTING TO EAT.
THERE'S GOT TO BE
A BETTER WAY.
- WELL, YOU GUYS ARE ALL EATING,
SO YOU FIGURED SOMETHING OUT.
MARILYN,
WHAT ARE YOU CHOMPING ON?
- OH, I'M ON THIS SPECIAL DIET
BECAUSE IT'S MY TIME
OF THE MONTH.
NO PUN INTENDED.
AND I'M EATING A--
- THERE WAS NO PUN THERE.
- THAT'S NOT A PUN.
- I DIDN'T GET A PUN.
- I'M EATING A VAGINATION
VAGINA MONOLOGUES ENERGY BAR,
AND IT IS AWESOME.
- JACK, WHAT DO YOU GOT IN--
SLOPPING IN YOUR MOUTH
OVER THERE?
- UM, THIS IS A--
IT'S WHAT THEY CALL
A BURGY-BURGY CHICK BURGER.
IT'S A CHICKEN BURGER WITH
TWO BEEF BURGERS AS THE BUN.
SO IT'S--IT'S GOOD.
- DOES IT FILL YOU UP?
- YOU KNOW WHAT,
IT DOESN'T DO THE TRICK, BUT--
- YOU NEED TO TOP IT OFF.
- YEAH, I TOP IT OFF WITH RANCH
AND THEN SOME--
- IS THAT WHAT THAT BUCKET IS?
- YEAH, A BUCKET OF RANCH.
- YOU'RE NOT CLEANING.
- NO, IT'S JUST A BUCKET
OF RANCH I USE--
- WHY ARE YOU DIPPING
YOUR MOP INTO IT?
- IT'S A TO-GO MOP.
[chomps]
[slurping]